I had the genetic testing done. How can I find out if I was tested for the following genes?
MTHFR, C-H-C-Y, C-L-M-T-M-T-T-R, R-M-T-R. I don't know how to read the book I was given.
So everybody, if you've had a genetic testing done through us, you were tested for these.
MTHFR is in the folate pathway. H-C-Y, C-L-M-T-R in the myopteran pathway. M-T-R, R, and M-T-R.
That's how you make B-12. These are in the methionine pathway. So these were tested for
and they're in your chart. So understand, though, there's common misconceptions out there. So
if you're googling these things or you're seeing Instagram posts about it, there's one nutritionist
quote-unquote. I don't even know who he is, but he, I just saw an Instagram video that basically
said, you know, these, if you have an M-T-H-F-R defect, I can't even remember because I
scrolled past it quick because this is stupidest thing in the world because he gave some threatening
thing that if you have an M-T-H-F-R defect, you know, this is the most common day in America that's
missed and this is what's causing cancer or something like that. That's just a bunch of holy balili.
So M-T-H-F-R defect is methyl tetrahedral folate reductase gene and you have two genes in
that family. That was one of the more research genes and one that was originally one of the
first ones that were tested in genetic testing and there's been a ton of misinformation about it.
And I have tons of videos on this that you should watch so that you can learn about them and you'll
learn about them in the Read Your Genes course, which all of you listening to this have access to.
You remember, you have full access to the Read Your Genes course, click on it, start watching some
of those videos that are in there. That will tell you all about these genes and I have different
videos on each one of these genes. So the reason why I bring this one up is because there's more
misinformation about that flying around the internet than probably anything on the planet and a lot of
well-meaning misunderstood practitioners will give somebody, you know, you have to get a methyl
group's methyl tetrahedral folate, which is the correct form of folate that person should be taking.
But because you have a gene defect on one of these two genes in this family, everybody needs to be
on that chronic, and that is just totally wrong, and that in fact can be very harmful, especially if you
have defects on the serotonin genes and the com genes in the biopterate pathway, you could actually
push, you know, taking too many methyl groups I have long said can, you know, turn off genes, which can
turn off tuber suppressor genes, but also take too many methyl groups who will push the biopterate
pathway, which will push an excess release of serotonin if you have defects on that gene that could cause
all sorts of emotional imbalances. The concrete has been tied to this has to do with biopterate,
which has to do with your transmitter function and neurotransmitter function, but it also has been
tied to breast cancer. So if you have defects in these genes, we have made recommendations on what
to take based upon those defects. So rest assured, we've already addressed these. The MTRR and the MTR gene
are how you cycle and create a denacyl comolamine and hydroxyl comolamine, which is B12. So this is
B12 production right here. If you have defects in that, we typically tell you that it might be going to
be taking a B12 supplement and what do we recommend, methyl B12. No, we typically recommend denacyl
comolamine or hydroxyl comolamine because excess methyl groups are not necessarily good for cancer